Is Jesus dependent or is he independent
on the Father?
There is an interdependency. There is an
interdependency. They depend on each
other. So inter- the inter-dependent,
the word means that they all rely on
each other, correct? That is correct. So
the Father relies on the Holy Spirit.
The Father relies on Jesus. Jesus relies
on the Father. Jesus relies on the Holy
Spirit vice versa. Yep.
So Jesus I know I know Jesus relies on
the Father, hence why he had to pray.
When Jesus was in God in human form, he
had to pray to the Father. But
Jesus prayed Jesus prayed to the Father
when he wasn't in human form. Prayer is
communicating and glorifying of the
divine. Which I The persons are not
going to stop glorifying each other or
communicating to each other just because
Jesus comes out. This is something that
they
from eternity's past and they continue
to So so So the word inter-dependent
means that they are all dependent on
each other. Yeah. So if you've got a
dependent being, how can that being be
almighty and a being. You don't have a
dependent being. To be a dependent being
means that you are depending on another
being outside of yourself. Yeah. In the
Trinity, they're not depending on a
different being. They depend on each
other as persons. They are the same
being. They're not depending on anything
outside of themselves. So so So if they
are the same being, if they are the same
being, why is the knowledge different if
they are the same being?
Their knowledge is the same though. Mark
13 Mark 13:32.
He knows the hour. That's declarative,
not ignorance. The word is oiden which
is telling now. The Holy Spirit doesn't
know the hour. And if they are
Show me where Show me where it says the
Holy Spirit doesn't know the hour. You
can't You can't answer that. You were
You were paused, bro. I couldn't hear
you. Mark 13:32. No, yeah. Where Where
does the Holy Where does the Bible say
the Holy Spirit doesn't know the hour?
If only the Father knows the hour, does
the Holy Spirit know the hour? Process
of elimination.
I just explained that to you. That the
word know is being used as a declarative
uh an announcement, not ignorance. As
the word is The Greek word is oiden
which Paul also uses when he says, "When
I came to you, I decided to know nothing
except Jesus Christ and him crucified."
Now when Paul says, "I decided to know
nothing," same Greek word oiden, "to
know nothing except Jesus Christ and him
crucified," does that mean that he
didn't know anything else other than
Jesus being crucified? No. Oh. So what
does that mean then? What does what
mean? When he says, "I decided to know
nothing. When I came to you, I decided
to know nothing except Jesus and him
crucified." What does that mean if it
doesn't mean he doesn't know everything?
That means that That means that that
he's not all-knowing cuz he only knows
that he came there for Jesus to be
crucified, which means he doesn't know
everything. I'm going to I'm going to
quote to you the verse again and I and I
want you to use your You're in a Islam
apologetics. So I'm going to grant it to
you that you can reason and you can
reason and you can understand. So I'm
going to give you the verse. He says
This is what Paul says. "When I came to
you," talking about the Corinthians
What verse? What verse? It's 1
Corinthians chapter 2. Yeah. He says,
"And when I came to you, brothers,
I did not come proclaiming to you the
testimony of God with lofty speech or
wisdom. For I decided to know nothing
among you except Jesus Christ and him
crucified." Yes. So he decided It was
his choice to not know anything at that
time other than Jesus being crucified.
So when he when he came to them
preaching as talking about Jesus Christ
and being crucified, did he not know his
own name? Jesus? No. No, Paul. Did he
not know his own name? No. So he didn't
know his own name. He didn't know the
people who he was talking to. Who? Paul
or Jesus? Are you on about Jesus? Hello.
Hello. Hello. Come on, bro. Come on.
Come on. How old are you?
Yeah, I'm 21. 21? Yeah. Why? Is that a
problem? Relatively. It may be a
problem.
Because For what reason? Cuz sometimes
when you're when you're not at when
you're at a certain age, you're supposed
to be mature enough to be able to follow
a conversation. But you're you're
showing me right now that you're not
mature enough to follow this
conversation, bro. No, I am mature. You
could have not answered. You could have
answered to me a basic question when I
said, "Is Jesus dependent on the
Father?" And you said, "No, no, no,"
because they're all they're all
independent and everything.
I'm going to I'm going to give you one
last chance, bro. I'll give you one last
chance.
Um
I'll give you one last chance. If you
can't follow the conversation, then uh
we're going to have to part ways. Fair
enough?
So you brought up Mark 13:32. Yeah. And
I told you about the word know. Yeah.
Oiden. What did I say about that word?
How So what did I say about The Greek
word oiden. You said She was just saying
how how he how he did know and that it
was just translated. No. Say it again,
bro. Please follow along. Are you
listening? Yeah, following along. All
right. The word oiden in Greek means to
announce or to tell, to make something
known.
Yeah, it's to declare. To declare. To
declare. Yeah. Paul uses the same word
in the verse that I just brought you to
in 1 Corinthians Yeah. chapter 2.
So he says, this is what Paul says to
the current people of Corinth. When he
came to them, he says, "When I came to
you, I decided to know nothing To
declare nothing. except among you except
Jesus Christ and him crucified." So
Jesus knew the hour. He knew the hour,
it's just not for him to declare it. So
how about the Holy How about the Holy
Spirit The Holy Spirit knows the hour.
It's not for him to declare it. It's for
the Father to declare. So the Holy
Spirit knows the hour. Absolutely. So
So is Jesus. So they're all on the same
level of intelligence. And you So if
they're all on They have the same divine
essence, my brother. Same divine
essence. What? So if they have all the
same divine essence, why is the Father
greater than Jesus? Because you have the
Father being greater than Jesus in role
and authority, not in essence. Similar
to how at work, your boss is greater to
you than in authority, but not greater
than you in nature because you're both
human, right? So Jesus, the Bible says
he humbles himself to the Father, takes
on the form of a servant. So that's why
he says that the Father is greater than
I because he's a servant of the Father,
submits to the Father's authority, while
at the same time they still hold have
the same essence. So he's greater The
Father is greater than Jesus in one
sense in authority and role, while Jesus
and the Father are equal in the sense
that they share the same essence. So
they're all They're equal. Yes, they're
equal and theological. Father, Son, and
Holy Spirit equal in essence. Well, that
is crazy, mate. That's what it is. It's
the Trinity. So So you believe in one
God Trinity? One God, three persons.
Three persons. So
Just Just to clarify, they all have the
same knowledge, so there's not lack of
knowledge in any in any any department.
That is correct. So only So Mark 13:32,
only that means that only the Father
declared. Correct. Here Let me Let me
share another nugget with you on this.
Okay. Jesus compares his coming cuz this
is what this is talking about, the last
hour, his coming. He compares his coming
to a wedding, a Jewish wedding. Yeah.
Yeah. Now according to a the Jewish
wedding, guess who it is who declares
the wedding?
The Is it Is that the Jewish dad? It's
the father Yes, it's the father of the
groom. Yeah. The groom and the bride,
they don't announce their own wedding
day. But the father of the groom does.
And so that doesn't mean that the groom
and the bride don't know their own
wedding day. Of course they know it.
They have to send out invitations. They
got to prepare for it. Obviously they
know their own wedding day. But in
respect for the Father, it's for him to
declare and make known the day. The same
thing is Jesus Jesus compares his coming
to a Jewish wedding. So So just like it
is he gives the respect to the Father.
So So So now that I've came to decide
that you do agree and even the Bible it
says that Jesus and the Father are one.
Is that correct? Yeah. Wait. Before we
move on, did you understand the point
about Mark 13:32?
Yeah, I understand that. I understand.
Thank you. Yeah. So do you believe that
Jesus and the Father are one, correct?
Yes. So if the Father declared, does
that not make it that the Jesus also
declared since they are one?
Well, well. Well, they're one in
essence. So they're distinct persons. So
that means like when the Father speaks,
that doesn't mean that the Son is also
saying those exact words.
So did Jesus declare the hour as well
cuz they are one? He didn't declare the
hour, but this is what happens. When the
Whenever the Father makes something
known, he does it through the Son. So
Whenever he Whenever he declares
something, he does it through the Son.
So whenever the Father declares
So would that be That should happen vice
versa because they are one, correct?
Whenever Jesus is revealing something,
revealing something, it's something You
can say that the the Father is also the
one who's revealing. No. Not No. The
Father gives Jesus the okay to do it.
No. You're Now you're avoiding the
question. The question was I answered
you directly on every question.
Yes Did Jesus declare the hour, yes or
no? No, he didn't. So even though So So
So does that go against So that
contradict when Jesus says, "I and the
Father are one"? No, it doesn't. Why
does that not contradict that? Show me
how it contradicts. Because I I I and
the Father are one, which means they are
one being, all knowledge, and they they
are one person just how just how you
guys believe There are three persons.
Why do you keep leaving that out? I
don't understand what it is about you
guys. You guys You Christians Okay. For
for for the life of yourselves, you guys
Like if somebody held a gun to your
head, you guys still wouldn't be able to
articulate the Trinity correctly. Okay.
Cuz Christians
At gunpoint, you wouldn't be able to do
it. Christians themselves like to
explain the Trinity such as you Are you
yourself? You've got But you've got your
soul. You've got your spirit. And you've
got And you've got your body. No. No.
No.
No. Is that correct?
No. How about the How about this then?
I've seen Christians and I've said,
"Water comes in three forms. It comes in
No. That's not the Trinity. That's not
the Trinity. So So that's not the
Trinity. So can you not display the
Trinity in worldly objects? You can't.
No.
You can't. What's the reason being? So
Someone who's not a Christian
Because there's nothing that share that
that is like God's nature. So what is
it? If you were able to point at
creation and be like, "See, God's nature
is like this. God's nature is like
that." Then that's not God. Now, what
you can do is you can point to certain
aspects and say and draw similarities,
but you could Well, you will never be
able to point to something in creation
and say that's what God is like. Like
that's what God is like in his nature.
You got to come back, bro, cuz remember
I can't hear you when you're when you're
I can't hear you when you're paused. I
don't know what happened to him.
Probably got a call.